des couleurs de la bonne humeur et l'
envie de partager du bonheur voilà
l'ambiance qui régnait sur l'historique
villa du département les associations se
sont mobilisées pour ses derniers
moments du nouvel an chinois
le nouvel an chinois est fêté en famille
et dans les jours qui viennent dans le
15ème jour c'est la fête des lanternes
et ce soir nous sommes dans ce beau site
de la villa du département pour fêter
c'est justement la fête des lanternes
qui clôture les festivités du nouvel an
dans cette société créole du multi
culturelle multi on va dire sensibilité
montrer le assister et faire connaître
les cultures et on va dire les
divertissements liés à nos origines est
important c'est par là la compréhension
de l'autre qu'on fait une plus grande
tolérance et la réunion est une société
de mai métissée et tout le monde après
s'il ya un bouchon et personne ne se
rappelle peut-être que le bouchon il est
hélas d'origine chinoise
deux mille personnes assiste ainsi à
l'entrée du dragon et des lions des
symboles qui font du bien c'est un
moment de joie mais nous avons aussi
pensée particulière voit la population
basque et frapper fort le problème
sanitaire et à travers le message que
nous voulons faire passer c'est que nous
avons toute notre confiance envers le
gouvernement
relever ce défi de surmonter sa crise
sanitaire 11 salles une application
celui d'airé données d'origine chinoise
et pour couvrir le court seulement de la
vie économique de l'île d'ager cette
année nous avons un lien mais le
consulat général
nous avons travaillé pour la mise en
oeuvre d'un projet qui est celui donc de
valoriser les boutiques chinoises à la
réunion et c'est important de célébrer
dans ce nouvel an chinois et je suis
tellement ému c'est que cette solidarité
de la communauté réunionnaise qui ont
réservé pour le peuple chinois en se
en ce temps de crise sanitaire et nous
sommes confiants de pouvoir vaincre cet
été vite épidémie avec les efforts du
peuple chinois
[Applaudissements]
si un jeune arrière
les spectacles réunionnais qui ont suivi
illustrer la présence asiatique forte
sur notre territoire
et voilà le sens même de notre histoire
une fraternité qui trouve son rôle dans
tous les moments de la vie